die bildungsmesse didacta in stuttgart
wurde abgesagt wegen corona die
erotikmesse occean 20 kilometer entfernt
in sindelfingen findet statt sechs uhr
früh lässt sich der krone sind ja dieses
land befallen hat besser beschreiben
kann es sein dass corona nicht nur die
lungen befällt sondern auch den verstand
derer die den kampf gegen das virus
organisieren
im kreis viersen in nrw schließen die
behörden ein gymnasium die realschule
gleich nebenan macht unterricht nach
plan
menschen die vielleicht krone haben
müssen 40 telefonate führen bis sich
jemand erbarmt sie zu testen
falls gerade sterile spatel vorrätig
sind jeder so scheint es kocht sein
eigenes süppchen und zurück bleibt eine
bevölkerung die auch deshalb völlig
verunsichert ist die leute rennen los
wie katzen den mann in schwarz
angezündet hat kaufen die apotheken leer
der infektions mittel zu astronomischen
preisen mundschutze die nichts helfen
nun aber in arztpraxen fehlen
sie kaufen konserven klopapier und
nudeln und zwar einen so absurden mengen
als seinen nudeln das einzig wirksame
gegenmittel gegen korona meine prognose
bei den gartenpartys 2020 wird
nudelsalat der absolute renner leute
beruhigt euch da draußen tobt nicht
ebola und auch nicht die beulenpest es
kassiert eine krankheit die sich allein
schon mit omas benimmregeln eindämmen
lässt öfter mal die hände waschen nicht
in der nase bohren nicht in die gegend
niesen und nicht die finger in den mund
stecken
wer sich traut weiterzuleben der kann
derzeit auch die schönen seiten in
zeiten von corona erleben kino theater
und sauna hat man im moment fast für
sich
flüge nach asien sind günstig wie nie im
januar und februar 2020 starben in
deutschland übrigens 202 menschen an der
grippe
das sind genau 202 mehr als ein corona
ja wir werden alle sterben aber mit
ziemlicher sicherheit nicht an krone